(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
Wow.
- Do you have this
effect everywhere you go?
- Well, the last time I was here
we didn't have these
beautiful people in the audience.
- That's right.
It was all virtual.
- Yeah.
- I know.
- [Vin Diesel] It was TVs.
I was looking at TVs with Xbox's.
- Now we only have six TVs.
We kept it a little bit
'cause it's kind of cool,
you can have people
from all over the world here, so.
- [Vin Diesel] Ooh, okay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay. I see the hard signal.
- [Kelly] There you go.
See, they're seeing us too.
- Are you moving to New York?
- We are moving to New York.
- I love that.
- We're very excited. Yeah.
- That's a New York love guys.
Come on guys.
- That's a New York love.
- I know.
I love, I, and even, even
so for my kids, like growing
up here, there's a lot of culture.
Yes. Growing up in New
York, there's a lot of
so either way they get,
that's a win for them.
- You're gonna love New York.
- Yeah.
Every time I'm there I love it.
Okay. You know why I
walk around everywhere?
Yes. No one walks here.
- No one walks here.
- Yeah. You sit in your
car for four hours.
- It's such a good point.
- Yeah. I was telling my kids, I said
because we live in LA most
of the time and you realize
that your kids haven't really
developed their swag walk yet.
And the reason is, when you
grow up in New York City
one of the first things you have to do
as a little kid is learn your swag walk.
- Gotta start working on mine.
- There's a swag walk.
Okay. That's the thing you
need when you're growing
up in New York City.
You have to swag, walk
to the train station
you have to swag, walk
through the subway cars.
- What is your swag walk?
Because like I feel like
when you look like you
you just walk.
Aw. Yeah.
Like I feel like people
like me, we need to work
on something.
But like, you just walk in
and like everyone's like
he cool, he's fine.
Aww. But you know.
Yeah. What is your walk?
I wish I could see it
as you as a young You
- A Young me?
- Yeah. A young You.
- Okay. I'll give you a young
- Give me young.
You can do it.
Fast, man.
(crowd cheering)
Oh my God, I'm so excited.
Pump it up.
(Vin Diesel grunting)
Pump it up
Pump it up.
- Okay. This is, this
is the real young me.
This is when I didn't have any money
(Kelly Laughing)
- Or after I redo my break dancing session
I would take off my hat and I'd go
Yes, credit cards are accepted.
(Kelly Laughing)
- So wait, speak.
- In fact
- Since I'm over here for a second
I'll tell you a little story
that I haven't told anybody.
- Oh my God. I wanna hear.
- So it was maybe
1983, '84 or something.
There's a place
in New York City called
Washington Square Park.
Anyone ever hear?
- Oh I just stayed there for like,
I had a-, I rented a house there.
That's a crazy place.
- It's a crazy place.
- Like, you walk outta
your house and you're like,
- what's good?
(crowd laughing)
I'm kidding.
- That can be a crazy place.
- So we used to break dance in...
- Yeah I know that park well
- And there was a, a comedian
named Charlie Barnett.
And Charlie Barnett used to climb a tree
and say "everybody showtime"
and he'd draw the biggest crowds.
And when he wanted to go
have Chinese food for lunch
he would let us entertain
the crowd with break dancing.
And one day he brought this little kid
this skinny little kid and he said
this little skinny kid is going
to be a great comic someday.
And we were jealous because
they made so much money
and the way you, the way
you kind of assessed how
much money you would make is
the pile of coins that you had.
And whenever the comedians did
the shows, they'd have cash.
And we only had coins basically.
And this young comedian
for the first time this
guy had introduced him
to New York was Dave Chappelle.
- Are you serious?
- That's how far that goes back.
- Wow. Have you ever
talked to him about that?
- I've never seen him again.
Oh my gosh.
This is the craziest story.
- What's good?
- Yeah
(Kelly clapping)
(Kelly and Vin Diesel laughing)
- no
It's, it's bizarre.
I'm, I'm only, I'm only saying
that now cuz I would, you know
I don't even think about the
past as much as I'd like to
as we should all reflect
more about the past.
It's because Kelly is
doing such a marvelous job
of taking me by asking me to do things
like what's your swag walk
(Kelly laughing)
that's gonna make me
start thinking about the good old days
- That is some Diane Sawyer right there.
- That's some Diane Sawyer right there
What's good?
- We are going.
- What's good?
(crowd cheering)
It's too much.
It's too much
- Move out of the way people
- This wasn't the idea.
I really, as I'm driving over
here, I was thinking, okay
you all know fast is coming out.
You know, I make this movie
with my heart and I'm thinking
what do I need to know?
And my daughter,
who's 15 wants to sing
and I'm thinking this is
the perfect opportunity
for me to ask Kelly what it's
like to have a magic ability
like her voice.
And what advice could I
give my 15 year old daughter
who has a dream of singing?
(crowd awing)
- Yeah
Dude, that's a, I mean I think
that Jesse and I would
probably say the same thing.
You just keep hustling.
We, we just kept, I
think people only know me
from American Idol, but you
don't know what I did before.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
And I think there's a
lot of hustle in there.
There are.
- That's real.
Like people will say, oh,
it must have been easy
for you when the show you have
Grammys of all these things.
I'm like, do you know how
many people said no to me?
You're to this, you're to that
- Oh my God
- You're not this
you need to be this.
It's like left and right
and like really there is no, there's no
there's no other advice
other than anything in life.
Like just do you, and
you know what I'm saying?
And people will follow.
Like even you said like you've been a part
of this franchise for, so
this is the 10th one, right?
- Yeah.
- 10th one.
That's because you love it.
It's apparent.
It's organic.
You have the chemistry
of all the characters
the fact that you have such longevity
with all the cast members
and they keep coming back
they keep loving to be a part of it.
(crowd cheering)
Like that's, that's rare.
(Vin Diesel clapping)
Like a lot of people don't do that.
So it's like sometimes magic happens.
But I think the thing
that I always tell people
on the voice too, like artists is like
quit trying to be another artist.
- Wow.
Be whoever you are because
we already have that artist.
So like, do what you do.
And even if it doesn't, like, you know
people have always said
like, oh well if you
if you don't pick
or you don't fit in this
box, it's not gonna work out.
I'm like, I literally
love every genre of music.
I work wherever I want.
Do whatever I want whenever.
And I think that's the key
is it's doing what you love
cuz you only get one life.
And I think we're reminded
of that the older we get.
You're gonna have to get her on here.
- Oh she would love to.
- Yeah. Alright.
Alright. Well I have to say this
because I think this is very beautiful
and poetic and magical.
I know that you and the late Paul Walker
y'all kind of have this thing
that's saying that y'all
you wanted it to last 10 10.
You were like, how many can we get
out of it, do you think,
with this franchise?
(crowd clapping)
And, and the goal, I heard
the goal was to get to 10.
Is that true?
- Paul and I started,
let me take you back.
We were in Mexico before the
first film had had ever opened.
We were sitting at an airport.
Our duffle bags were at the side
we were sitting on the floor.
We had just come
from this place called MTV
Spring Break thing that they had.
- I've done that before.
- You know what I mean?
- That's crazy.
- It was crazy.
And he said to me,
"Vin take all this in"
as people are walking over our
feet and not looking at us.
And he said, "take in the fact
that we have anonymity
because once this movie comes out
we will no longer have anonymity."
(crowd clapping)
- Aw. That's the pride in that.
That's amazing.
You believed in it.
- He believed in it.
He believed in it.
And he would always say,
whenever we would go
to a premiere around the
world, um whenever I would exit
the theater would only be him and I.
No other directors, writers,
producers, studio cast
nobody would just have to be him
And I and he'd always
whisper in my ear and say
"Vin the best ones still in the can."
And we were doing an interview
in London and they asked him
we had just done six and they said
is there gonna be another one?
And he said, "Vin, is
there gonna be anymore?
Is there gonna be a a seven
and eight and a nine?"
And I said, the question
isn't, is it seven?
I'm I'm gonna confuse you.
7, 8, 9.
It's, is it 7, 8, 9, 10?
And when I said 10, he
looked at me and said
if we ever got to 10
we would do something no one's ever done
in cinematic history
And that.
(crowd clapping)
- So it's incredible that like,
I know he is there in spirit
and at heart, but he wasn't
able to be there for this 10.
But it's incredible to know that, you know
whatever you believe in
he's looking down going, they did it.
They made it to 10.
That's incredible.
It's an incredible franchise.
- It's, it's so, it's so crazy
and, and I'm so grateful.
You know
this is a franchise that's
never had an inherited fan.
Meaning there's never been a comic book
there's never been a TV show
- Ground up
- Ground up.
And it's just from you all
and the love that you all have that
- Yeah.
- Has continued on this and and who
who knew that in, in 2023,
that we would need a saga
like this to remind us
how important family is.
- Yeah.
- How important it is to
love each other, you know?
Yeah.
- I, and I love too that
you did it in two parts.
It's so funny cuz we've
always known Fast and Furious.
So it's, it's so amazing.
- Like Yeah.
- Is that your idea?
To split it up into two,
like Fast and then Furious?
- It was, maybe it was
the studio idea because
- It's really good
- To wrap up the finale.
There's so many characters,
so many beloved characters of
- And new one's coming in
- And new one's coming in.
- Yeah.
- That you need more than just two hours.
So their concept was can you do,
- Yeah.
- Can you break it into two?
- Is this the part where you're talking
about you're doing something
that no one's done before?
I'm like, that's that's the part
in the movie where you're like
they are not, they did, they're doing it.
You're watching it and
you're like, oh my God
- We've done some crazy things.
- Yeah. So, okay.
The cast, the cast of the Fast
and Furious movie is get
more and more incredible.
So let's go through some new
people in this latest one.
Okay. Because we're gonna
start with Dame Helen Mien.
Oh. Who, who would've thought like
who would've thought Dame?
Hell Mi like, I just, it's incredible.
- I was It's incredible.
- I love her.
She's incredible.
Yeah. I love her.
She, she came here and I fell
in love with her all over again.
So what was it like
like talk about your
first day meeting her.
- Oh, first day meeting her, I was at a
at my agent's Oscar party
and she had been doing
interviews saying, they said
what do you wanna do next?
And she's saying, I want
to be in Fast and Furious.
And they're like, what?
And so she came up to me
and she said, Hey Vin, dude
haven't you heard I want
to be in Fast and Furious.
- Oh my God it's pretty good.
- And I'm like, but really we're we're
about to film in a week.
She said I don't care.
You're the producer get it together.
Oh my god.
- She's so bold.
She was to be a part of the movie.
She's ok.
- Please.
- I love it.
- It was great.
And she's amazing and what
she brings, she's so talented.
- Yeah. Okay, I'm gonna
go to Bree Larson Now
is it true that her character
is based on your daughter?
- Yes.
- Which is so great.
How proud is your daughter?
That's so cool too.
- Oh God.
Yes. So
- How so?
- Well she, my older daughter
she came to my older daughter's birthday
and my younger daughter, Pauline,
who I named Paul
- Yeah.
- Um Was wearing a good vibes only shirt
and she just has this kind of confidence
and so she modeled the
character after, after Pauline.
And it's just the most adorable thing.
- I love that.
I love that y'all are attending
birthday parties, like off.
- Yeah.
- That's a family.
That's nice.
What about, I love Rita Moreno.
She's been here and I'll
tell you what, that woman
I don't believe her age.
- Nope.
- I do.
I don't, I don't believe it.
I don't even care if you show
me the birth certificate.
It's a lie.
- No, that I couldn't agree with you more.
- That woman literally
She seems 20 years younger than
She actually is.
It's crazy.
Were you,
- Oh God.
- Were you a fan of West Side Story?
Like
- Oh my God.
Was I a fan of it?
Yeah. I grew up there.
- Oh Duh. I didn't even think
- I'm thinking of, when I'm
thinking of West Side Story
I'm thinking of those streets.
Those
- Yeah.
- I'm like, that's just
right around the corner.
- Yeah. How did that happen?
How did she become a part of it?
- We were getting an award
in New York, some Icon award
or something and it was,
we were both recipients
and when I got up there, I
just started talking about her.
Cause coming from New York City
in New York City all over the world.
But she's a huge hero.
We, you know, we all love
like Sidney Portier who got an Oscar
in I guess 1967
but nobody really considers that.
Five years before that
Rita Moreno was the first
Latin woman to receive an Oscar.
And so she's a, she's a a
source of so much pride.
- Yeah.
- And for all these kids in New York.
- She was a testament
that you could do it.
So she was an idol to us.
- I'm just gonna write
that off as cuz women make
it look easy.
What?
- Ohh
- They're like, I'm just
saying, I'm just saying
- Listen
- I'm a huge fan of hers
too, just in general.
She's just a firecracker man.
- She's a firecracker.
- Livin like, she's like such a lesson
in how you should live your life.
Just living.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
I'm gonna talk about this one.
So Jason, mom Momoa,
he's the bad guy, right?
- He is the bad guy.
- Okay. Okay.
- What do you love?
I love, I love him playing a bad guy.
I think that's fun.
- Oh, he kills it.
- Yeah. He's got those evil eyebrows.
You know, he's got a, yeah
- He, one of the things, one
of the things that has
served the franchise well
is allowing people to
really explore and to
create characters that they've
always wanted to create.
- Yeah.
- And he does that very thing.
- Oh
- You see him relish in the idea
of playing a villain and playing it
with these unique nuances
and characteristics.
- Yeah.
- And it's really fun to watch.
- Yeah. It's so fun.
Cuz he plays like Aquaman
and an evil person.
- Yeah.
Like, no, he kills it in this
- And it's fun for actors probably too,
that y'all allow them
that creativity and allow them to go
out of like being pigeonholed.
That's amazing.
- It's A beautiful
- So speaking of that, I hear
that you have like a dream
casting for the final film.
Who, who is that?
Other than me?
I'm just kidding.
Do you wanna say it or
you don't wanna say it?
Are you too ?
- Ow.
- What do you mean?
- That happened to me one time.
I was doing Riddick, right.
And I had the eye
the contact eyes in,
has anyone seen Riddick?
Yes. Okay.
(crowd clapping)
So I'm doing Riddick
and I have those contact
I couldn't see, right?
So I'm walking through this set
and my head hit the
spaceship and I'm walking
to the set and now I'm
bleeding in this whatever.
- Oh my God.
We're the, you
- You don't want to hear all that.
That's too much.
Right?
Too much.
- We love to talk about that.
- Oh It's too much.
I act like I'm on a talk show.
- Everybody give it up for Vin Diesel.
We always love when you come visit us.
The first part of the finale
of the Fast Furious franchise
is called Fast 10 everybody
It's in theaters
everywhere starting May 19.